une fin de non recevoir pour le
ministère du travail
amazon france ne peut être éligible
chômage partiel car la fermeture des
sites du groupe n'est pas liée à une
baisse d'activité mais à une décision de
justice
la plateforme a en effet décidé le 15
avril dernier de fermer six entrepôts en
france une décision qui survenait après
un jugement du tribunal de nanterre lui
imposant de limiter ses activités à une
liste de produits d'hygiène alimentaires
et médicaux ainsi qu'à réévaluer les
risques sanitaires liés aux qu'ovide 19
malgré un arrêt de la cour d'appel de
versailles
élargissant la liste des produits
autorisés la direction d' amazon a
maintenu la fermeture de ses sites en
cause selon elle la décision de la
justice d'infliger des amendes de 100
mille euros en cas d'infraction en
risques financiers qui seraient trop
importants pour son activité notre
activité logistique et techniquement
complexe et l'astreinte de 100 mille
euros par infraction précisé par la cour
d'appel pourrait impliquer que même un
taux un film de traitement accidentels
de produits non autorisés de l'ordre de
0,1 pour cent pourrait entraîner une
pénalité de plus d'un milliard d'euros
par semaine cette demande de chômage
partiel émises par la direction d'amazon
france est vivement critiqué par les
principaux syndicats du groupe dans un
communiqué la cgt la cfdt et sud
la qualifie de proprement à descente
précisons que le chômage partiel est
destiné aux entreprises dont l'activité
est rendue impossible par le contexte
actuel dans les faits pourtant les
affaires n'ont pas complètement cessé en
france amazon continue ainsi d'effectuer
une partie de ses livraisons depuis ses
entrepôts situés à l'étranger notamment
en allemagne en italie au royaume uni la
plateforme de commerce en ligne a pour
l'instant prévu de fermer ses entrepôts
dans l'hexagone jusqu'au 5 mai les
syndicats ont proposé à la direction
d'amazon france une reprise progressive
d'activité